Hey, what's happening? Is your boy Peww...  what has my life become...
Who am I?
What am I?
please
kill me
Welcome to ultimate battle simulator
Ss-sorry ultimate Epic battle simulator this is why you clicked on this channel isn't it because we want action
hardcore!
Badassery!
and...
Epicness! hey guys to be tech here and today
I'm going to show you how to mine so fast that you can't even dig a straight hole so in this game me for you
For some reason aren't familiar with this
yeah, you can simulate where's
W-what is this game about?   You can simulate war's!
Now I have a pretty strong Computer
it could run Roblox on Max settings, so let's see...
what we can do.  SIX-HUNDRED-AND-SIX...
NAZI'S!  And another  Six. And another...
*ahahahahaha*
and another
*ahahahahaa*
That's how many nazis versus one
Table
(Mind blown, Pewds.  Mind. Blown.)
Oh my God. Yes, no, it's not lagging at all
What I got four FPS going in...
that is a lot of fucking Nazis thoug...
Jesus Christ
And maybe I shouldn't have picked so many
got a solid 60 FPS going on here.
Well, maybe I shouldn't have made so many you know...
*ehm ne mhnemne*
*he*
Maybe I exaggerated just a little bit with this whole table *hehehehe*.
Oh My god, how many did I make, Jesus Christ?
What the ff..
I got two FPS
*he*
Let the battle begin
*epic music starts playing*
go forth my Nazi's! You kill The Table I
Y-you kill the table!
I don't know...
Euh, it's avalanche
I-i don't know what's happening, but im sure it's pretty epic...
I think I just nuked all the nazis. I don't know I have one framerate. Maybe let's *ehh* let's exit. Okay
Let's try that again okay. Oh, Jesus Christ. I had
666666 (Illuminati confirmed) pick up let's just remove one of them. All right. Let's remove one of them, and then we can see
Maybe don't act. Okay here. We go. Yeah. That's a lot better. Well now we have a decent framerate
There you go Nazi's
All right
Okay, a lotta nazi's. They're very angry. They're very angry at the
Table, where is table there he is, go
*HueHueHueHa*
Table, you can do it begin no table nooooooo
TABLE!!!
Damn it
*Sad Music* RIP Table may his Soul Be remembered forever :'(
an
Equal amount of tables as there are German Soldiers tonight
We dine in on table as they said I feel like I need to have an epic battle speech to my table
MY FELLOW TABLES,
WE'VE COME THIS FAR!!!
TO FIGHT FOR OUR FREEDOM!
THOSE NAZI SCUM!
THOSE FILTHY GERMANS!
I BET THEY WATCH PEWDIEPIE (Confirmed)
THOSE SON'S A BITCHES (WHAT TF IS HE SAYING),
WE WILL NOT LET THEM DINE UPON US.
WE WILL NOT LET 'EM NOT USE COASTERS!!
THEY DO NOT RESPECT  WOOD.   THEY DO NOT RESPECT THE HARD SURFACE OF A  NICELY POLISHED
WOODEN TABLE.
That's what?
Oh, Jesus.  JESUS CHRIST, NO TABLES!!!
Taableeess!!!!
Ugh
Bye dammit, they built a shield yes!
Omg the Nazi's are fighting strong.
But they have no match against the tables actually the tables are getting rekt no
I possess this Table
Hold your line tables. HOLD YOUR LINE.
Stand your ground!
Table
not today (BTS not today?!)
not today
They're getting fucking Rekted
This is so fucking retarded
long ago the four nations lived Together in Harmony
then everything changed when fire nation attacked
*EAR RAPE*
Guess now we know if they bunch of nazis
fought against a buncha tables
Nazis would win, okay? duly noted Let's make it a little bit more interesting all right the will happen
We'll have table over here. All right. We'll have dressers
Fighting tables, and then here we'll have one Chuck Norris will have 200 Santa clauses
Catapult
250 Zombie and
one Dwarf
*Brave Gimli* And my axe. Here we go. All right. We got a tables
Hoorah Hoorah
tables, TABLES!!
Come on. My money's on tables. I don't know about you, bro's
I don't know about you bros. VS Dresser that
filthy disgusting
Despicable dressers. I bet they don't even dress themselves. I bet their mamas versus a bunch of fucking catapults
yeah, they're probably going to win. Versus from the other corner!
SANTA CLAUSE! that's right ho ho ho going to fuck some bitches up?
But where is chuck nerris, where is he, the man, the myth, the legend there he is
He looks angry.., he looks angry im not going to lie
Versus, what is that, Dwarfs, okay fuck it
And eh fucking zombies I don't know, alright go
All right dressers they're moving in, they seem a bit confused
But they're fighting, oh and They're dressers are getting wrecked by the catapults
Tables are standing strong
against santa clause
But Santa Clause  not like table. No they do not they are fucking them tables up
Oh, but it looks like UGH, it looks like the dressers have killed santa, the dressers have killed santa, MY GOD
Who would win Santa Clause or tables?
The santa clause are fighting strong.
But thank you they have enough against all these tables (He might of meant do they???)
We'll find out but oh my God look at all the dead dressers
It looks like they have a trouble fighting back against the catapult, but the dressers
Are fighting strong against the catapults because the ones that made it in they can defend themselves against
We underestimated
the dressers killed everyone one furniture versus another
but who will win?  the santa clauses are dead!
Yes a carpet for the tables
They had no match for tables, but will the dressers win!? Or will the tables stand strong?
They still have to fight against catapults, the catapults have strategically turned back but there are still some brave
No, they're a not there are no more dressers. They stand no chance theres dressers are moving in
from the, right
But will they make it they are dying fast
RIP DRESSERS :'(
War, Has Changed
It's no longer about nations, ideologies, or ethnicity
It's an endless series of Proxy Battles fought by Mercenaries and machines
War and its consumption of life
Has become a well-oiled machine?
it's table
It's Table versus Dress, but the battle is not yet won
There's too many tables
There's too many, Whoa Chuck Norris is still alive, CHUCK NORRIS IS STILL ALIVE! And hes breaking them dressers
left and right... MY GOD!
My God he's older, strong
I can't stop yelling but jesus christ
OH MY GOD
A random nuke just hit chuck norris, wait he's still alive WTF, another random nuke
What the how is he still
Piranha, How many
Chuck Norris is killing off!  He's kicking the  Tables!  He's punching the tables!
Come on table come on
The battle is over the last table takes its last breath and the winner is Check Nerris.